I've got all day for research today.
Few things I got to handle later in the
evening. At least I get a whole bunch of
hours right now to do some research.
have a bit of coffee, talk a little bit
about the plan for today, and then I'll
switch it over to the uh the stream
view.
The goal for today, we're going to be
working on the new large scale viz
project.
I should have about 2400 experiments, if
they've finished, uh that I've run
overnight. We'll see if they're done
yet.
And if so, we'll copy those over.
Uh, I'm probably going to spend a little
time thinking about whether I have the
visualizations right. I'm probably going
to spend a little time working on the uh
the port of this visualization software,
the Puffer Native.
I might work on a little bit of tooling
to make uh the launching and management
of these experiments a little easier.
And we will see from there.
It's nice to be back to peace, quiet,
and uh research. Certainly, I've not
done anything this morning that will
disturb the peace and quiet.
Okay. So, here is
the current visualization.
This is the current set of data that we
have.
And I believe that we can go now take a
look at
This one's done.
This was Pac-Man.
I'm just generating uh generating the
plots here.
Have to come up with a better way of
managing these later today.
That should have generated it.
didn't already have Pac-Man in here,
right?
show up.
Yes, it does. Oh, that's a very nice
one. Look at that. You see the gray for
Pac-Man?
pretty cool curve. Anything that's get
has like this sort of slant to it. I
believe
like this sort of slant means that
they're more steps equals more
performance. You can kind of see like
this would be the 2D slice of the graph,
right?
And that some of these have more of a
slant to them than others. some like you
don't really get so much from this.
We'll come up with more stuff from here,
I'm sure.
Chat's working, right? Yeah, it should
be right down there.
Okay. Um, so
we have the visuals for this. Uh, I
should probably queue up.
I should probably get something queued
up.
We don't have triple triad on here,
right?
Yeah, we don't have triple triad.
Is there a reason I didn't do this? No
CUDA GPUs.
Stupid Docker
I just need to see if it has a Perf
metric
and if so I can just launch this.
we can actually do this verbose thing
now, right?
>> Hello. Welcome. What am I making today?
To be determined. I'm going to start by
fixing up a couple small things with the
uh experiment management for this new
constellation project. And then I think
I'm going to work today. I'm going to
kind of just chill and spend some time
porting this to C. I want to see if I
can like my expectation is that I can
probably in less than a thousand lines
have this entire UI in C and have it
super fast and uh if I can do that then
like I have this on my local browser but
it's really annoying to host this crap
if I want to have this on the website
and it's also pretty slow. If I get this
thing into C, I can actually not only
make it nicer, uh, but I can host this
on the website as a standalone really,
really easily. So, imagine being able to
have like this level of data and you
just play with it in your browser.
What do you think stopping mass people
from using puffer instead of old gym?
They are using puffer.
Look at this.
This is like probably the fastest
growing RL project.
Um,
for comparison,
this one literally has meta branding.
I don't think they've passed me, have
they? No, they haven't. So, yeah, we've
literally passed the meta branded RL
library that was made before Puffer.
So,
this is just like good growth. We have
like 2,000 people in the Discord now. It
just takes time to get full uh full
adoption,
but it'll be there because it's
literally impossible to do any
reasonable work with the old gym stuff.
It's just too slow.
The only other thing I see people doing
is like the jack stuff, but it's just
slower and harder. So, there's really
not much point.
All right, this is fine.
And we need uh train
So now it should show us this, right?
Yeah,
we've got PF on here. Perfect.
and now presumably
we will get uh results for this later
today.
so this is what I started working on um
for the local version. I didn't get
super far.
How do I fix this?
Oh, there's this obnoxious Docker thing
locally, isn't there?
You know, I bet that this is just
driver. I bet this is just the docker
being stupid.
But if I just reboot the docker
There we go.
So, we're going to actually get a
plotting thing done. I think we're going
to get this ported. We can have this
visualization in
and all these in uh PureC as a
standalone dashboard. That'll be really
nice. Welcome, Jess.
ever get around to adding the finance
end?
I've been meaning to, Jess.
It actually does make sense. It's not
like a super impressive one though. It's
like we have more complex ones for
clients. This was the one that we could
release.
The new uh the new training program is
going to be pretty tough.
First week is always the worst as well.
The tough thing is the new running
trail.
The new running trail is not easy. It's
about It's a little shorter actually,
about 5 and a half miles, maybe 5 and
3/4 miles. Um but the ground is very
soft.
So
it's just hard.
So the plan is I do that in the morning.
So hour long run. I get an hour's worth
of lifting weights in while I'm doing my
research throughout the day. Then I get
an hour's worth of flexibility training
before bed.
and we will see from there.
Okay. So,
right,
I actually made a little progress on
this on my laptop. Let me go grab my
laptop so I can sync over the couple
things I added to this. Uh because I
figured one cool thing out from
any recommendations for someone getting
into weightlifting?
If you mean weightlifting as the Olympic
sport, I don't do weightlifting, so I
don't know. If you mean general strength
training with like heavy compound lifts,
simple 5x5 is the easiest thing for a
lot of people to start with. You'll go
through phases where you have to fix
little technical things here and there.
Um, but it's really not that technical
of a of a discipline. That's why I like
it.
Um,
let me
yeah, literally just like basic strong
lifts 5x5 is
like if you're just getting into it,
that'll take you through your first year
at least.
I just I got my
laptop to sync work. also
get correct calories and protein.
Those are the two that really matter.
Everything else is kind of minor. Sleep.
Sleep is big.
I mean, but this is all like stuff you
should just be doing anyways.
Right.
I mean, you would just code it in right
to the end
as a parameter.
So, a lot of the times I get asked like,
why don't you just do this as a feature,
right? Like, because I could add
something where you delay observations
by 20 steps or whatever.
But like
the thing is that the complexity of
doing the general version of it is
usually not worth it unless it's like
every env is going to want this,
right? So like why do we have our end
binding thing in C like our like a
multiple environment binding thing?
Because every end uses it and it's kind
of annoying to get right.
Okay,
is this done?
Okay. So the only difference here the
thing that I added to this I did this on
the plane over.
Yeah. Right here. So
this is the plot function. And now
there's an additional buffer, a render
texture. So we can do different plots in
different render textures.
So kind of a couple different pieces to
this. There's data loading.
There is the plotting itself.
What types of plots do I use here?
I really just have um aside from these
specialty ones at the bottom, I need to
just have a 2D and 3D scatter plot,
right?
With different colorations.
Maybe not even with different
colorations.
Just call it in a loop, right?
Well, you then you need hang on.
You want to be able to have multiple
draw calls.
So that means you need the axis.
Morning 1:00 a.m.
Yeah. Dashboard.
We're going to try to get this into C.
I'm just thinking about the best way to
set a couple things up.
Hey, welcome Yaxian.
Um I am here thinking about the nicest
way to port this. I'm thinking because I
wanted to do this whole thing um like
just one like in one big call.
But the thing I'm thinking right is if I
do that I actually need to compute the
axes up front for all the different
plots
because otherwise like this has to be
multiple draw calls. You actually don't
want to have a plotting library that
can't do multiple draw calls on the same
plot.
What are you on about, man?
This is we're looking at uh this is the
new project. This is Puffer
Constellation.
Hopefully, this will be the basis of
Puffer 40. The results that come out of
this, this is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8. So far,
nine environments, at least 1,200
experiments per environment, aggregated
Purto points, a whole bunch of insights
on X's end. Yeah, they should have kept
you to fix it, right?
Okay. So, I think all I got to do here
then is
Okay, so there are two problems here.
The easiest thing would be
to just have this be uh part of the plot
arcs, right?
What can I use as I
can I use something as a uh
is there a way to have like um I guess I
just have to put some sort of dumb
sentinel, All right.
This just needs this thing.
Of course, you end up duplicating the
freaking width and height annoyance.
what are you using for autocomplete
super maven?
The idea is it's a really stupid model
but it's really fast. It saves typing
but not thinking.
Mhm.
And I have to do this for
Yeah, I have to do this for all three
axes.
That might save a little bit of code, I
suppose, right?
Which one did I miss?
XY
min X.
And we don't have 3D yet, so we'll leave
this
really
what's the order of ops on this? I would
assume that it would be um
you know the expression before the
Whoops. I would assume that this
parenthesy should be implied, but maybe
not.
Uh,
really?
Oh, no. I know what it is. Hang on. I'm
dumb.
I know what it is.
curious what your take on off Paul?
with regular arrays ED3
behavioral cloning
it's very simple you're doing RL to the
extent that you are interacting with an
environment to collect your data.
So if you have some interaction but
you're doing some other stuff with a
data set that's like not from
interaction
then you're doing some stuff that's RL
and then some other Enough.
Well, this seems fine then, right?
So, what's wrong with it?
Oh,
I don't know how I did that.
Dash left X and buggy chats are back.
Yep,
that's how it works.
All right. So, this is fine, right?
We've got our array maxes. Um,
right? So, this now should allow us
to do this across a bunch of different
plots
potentially here, right?
Yeah, because
you kind of need this thing to be
scaled.
Uh,
it's not that I'm not a fan of off
policy. It's that I have empirical
evidence that it's algorithmically
inferior.
Okay. So, the thing I'm trying to figure
out here, right, like
the normal way you would do this is you
would have
[Music]
I'm trying to think if I have to do this
in pixel space. I think I might have to
do this in pixel space.
But like if I do that then how the heck
am I going to do
Like the issue here, right, is I could
just say, "Okay, we're going to let
there be a camera and we're just going
to put the the uh points at the spots in
in uh the world space that they're
supposed to go. But then we have to
scale everything with the camera,
weirdly.
But like I have to do this anyways,
don't I? For 3D.
Pretty sure I have to do this anyways
for 3D
cuz like otherwise then what? I have to
make my own freaking camera.
I guess
the thing is the alternative is also
really obnoxious.
Like the alternative is that I have to
wait until I you basically don't get to
do eager mode graphics.
Hang on. Maybe we just ignore
like we don't really need these
automatic axes, right?
Like they're kind of just annoying. We
don't have to do a fully featured
plot library. We just have to do the
minimal thing. So if we ignore the
automatic axis, does it get easier?
Yeah. Yeah, it does. Right.
Why is this so hard?
It should be relatively easy, shouldn't
it?
It feels more difficult. I feel like I'm
making it more difficult on myself than
it should be.
Wonder devs can expose change of
thoughts.
Oh, you got to the conclusion so
quickly.
Oh, it's it is actually exposed. It's
just that you have to uh apply
interaction with the dev in order to
ascertain what exactly it is.
Wait. So if I have this, then literally
all I have to do
bothers the heck out of me that I'm like
I don't know what the heck is wrong with
me with
There's probably something complex here
that I'm just not understanding.
I mean, first of all, I didn't want it
to be reading CSV. I needed to read JSON
now, right?
Yeah, we're not doing a freaking make
project.
Okay, we can try this
for for JSON
and then I'll have to give it like some
sample Oh,
and then you shouldn't need utils,
right? Oops. You should just need this.
It's MIT license, right? Yeah.
Six lines.
How long is this library?
Kind of long, but okay.
Does this thing have a read from file or
is it just as a string?
Okay,
I can probably get Grock to just give me
example usage
since I think this doesn't do file IO.
Uh I'm pretty sure it's just going to be
like read it into a char buffer, right?
But here, let me let me see because this
thing probably is like that's a big
enough library that it's probably seen a
whole bunch of examples of it.
what do I have the format of this thing
This
looks like it.
It looks like it.
like yeah this is more code than using
uh this is more code than Python but
it's really simple code if you look at
have to look through this as well.
Um,
Got to include it. I need more coffee is
what I need.
Is everyone everywhere
or coffee?
I get good sleep.
I made this prototype with a dash
large scale data analysis tool and such
for RL and I'm currently trying to port
it to C because
well it'll be a lot easier if it's in C,
believe it or not.
I don't know, maybe I just hate
JavaScript that much,
but I think it's going to be better in C
than JavaScript.
plus Python plus whatever the hell else
Dash uses. Let me grab coffee and a set
or
Yeah, this is ideally going to be we'll
see what results we get out of this, but
this is ideally going to be a big thing
of puffer 4.
And my grip just sucks.
I do one set of deadlifts and it's just
like worked.
as he is. Yeah, this is the goal is that
I'm going to be on a lot more.
I shouldn't need to link this, right? Am
I dumb?
I have it in the same folder.
I thought I didn't I didn't think I
needed to link
to link it if I have it like this.
Oh, right. Damn it.
I don't know why people do this.
here. We'll do this for now.
And why can't people just make header
libraries? It's like so much freaking
easier.
doing competitive programming help in RL
in general. I did not do any competitive
programming. I've never done a
hackathon. Never did any competitive
math. I've not done a single thing of
that type. I did a whole bunch of
projects. I spent a lot of time trying
to think about research and get better
at doing research and doing like harder
and harder projects, that sort of thing.
Oh,
how the hell? Wait.
I see. It's because I'm combining. Cool.
So score is not an array. Okay.
Oh, you know Why?
I know why.
Now, um,
[Music]
my tendency is going to be that we have
we're probably going to want to have
like one little Python script
uh, that turns all the data into
something that is as close as possible
as what we want rather than doing a ton
of string processing in C.
C is not a particularly fun language to
do string processing in.
It's great for pretty much everything
else.
I mean, it is a great language if you
really want fast spring processing, I
guess. But
Have people yelling at me on the
internet yet?
Apparently, if you write a um
a entire bait, not really bait, but if
you would write an entire like kind of
jerk article, it's way better than
writing just a two-line jerk tweet.
I mean, there's a lot of stuff I need to
do with this realistically, right?
Wait, shouldn't this cache file have
No, this cache file doesn't have stuff
filtered in it yet.
That's okay, though. So, we need to do
uh draw the axes.
That's not going to be in the right
spot, but let's see.
Okay.
So, this needs to be
I think that there's like a text width
in Ray Libas
Do you recommend training on collab? I
do not have a GPU. Ooh,
Collab's kind of bad. Um,
if you want to rent GPUs for cheap,
I'm not affiliated with these guys. Um,
they just tend to have the cheapest.
31 cents for 4090, 36 cents for 5090.
Ignore all of these.
Oh, yeah. Literally, look, some of the
cheaper cards you can get for like
nothing.
5 cents at 3070, 8 cents at 4070.
You can very easily get yourself a cheap
card. We also have all these nice
machines that you can see sitting behind
me. Uh we do give collaborators access
to those if you've built a couple cool
environments and need some to do more
cool RL.
Close this. I wanted to be looking at
that crap.
Okay, I see string size.
This is pretty nice.
Not a compile time constant.
Lovely.
Okay, this is not it.
Let's uh figure out why.
Who says you can't do UX and see?
Can absolutely do UX and see?
You want to learn and try things, but
you lack hardware. So, Aziz,
it really depends on your financial
situation. Um, I've brought down the
entry barrier to doing like pretty
competent RL research to just having a
good desktop.
I've brought it down from like you need
to be freaking Google to really be
effective to like you can do a lot with
a desktop. Um, or at least that's a bit
Well, no, actually that's pretty
accurate.
Um, and I've even bought a whole bunch
of these desktops. And pretty much the
main purpose of these is so that I have
hardware to give to collaborators.
That doesn't mean I just give it out
randomly, right? It's if you're actually
building cool stuff and contributing
things to Puffer, I give people access.
But
there's only so much I can do to bring
the barrier down. Maybe by next update
it'll be 500,000 on CPU. Who knows?
Maybe it's worth me doing a little CPU
optimization. I don't know. We'll see.
The one thing I have zero sympathy for
is the like, oh, I don't have a GPU. All
I have is this $4,000 MacBook.
That's like, all right, that's
self-inflicted.
Well, it freaking happens, right?
So,
Man, Rayson is just the best.
This is just the best project.
Rail just makes me happy.
Like, yay, you can have code that
doesn't suck.
Okay, but now this bit is going to be a
little annoying. So, this has got to be
draw text pro. And then we do args font
y label. Yeah. Then it's going to be
vector 2
and
This one is going to be
args margin
minus
font size
or y font size doy over two because it's
rotated.
And then the height,
the height is going to be height over
two plus
And then the rotation
origin is going to be thisation
is going to be 90
font size zero
of white.
And then this has got to be Can I give
it a negative rotation? Will it be
happy?
Somebody wants to find me a decent font
for this, that'd be awesome. I think
Ryson has a few of them. Obviously, one
that I don't need to license.
I guess technically if you can license
it for the whole project, then like
whatever.
I think it's time for another set.
Trying to think what I want to do today.
Let's get in a third set of pull-ups and
then I'll go on to uh other back stuff.
You know what I need to do is I need to
buy myself a dip belt here because I
usually do weighted pull-ups and the
body weight pull-ups are kind of lame.
I wonder if anybody else has done
something similar.
Is there anything I can do um to make
this easier on myself so I'm not like
literally implementing
the core of map plot lab or something?
I guess it's not terrible to be doing
this. It's kind of chill
and like this is actually going to
result in something very useful. So
it kind of makes more sense that this
doesn't exist.
Like if you think about it, probably not
wanting to do like uh core figure setup
is the reason that there aren't more
plotting libraries. Like half the
plotting libraries out there just matt
plot lip as a back
We don't really need these to be
doubles.
Oh, you can't do this, right? Because
you can't return a charar.
Can you return an array?
I don't think you can even do that, can
you?
I think I just do the uh the 2D case
first and then afterwards we're going to
worry about like this whole
this whole nonsense, right?
I don't really like how this like snaps
back and forth like this. Do you? I
think I would always just rather have uh
have it align with the coordinate
system.
I honestly should have just started
writing it myself. It would be done by
now. I don't know why I'm being lazy
today.
It's just like such an obnoxious little
thing, right?
Oh, this does it, doesn't it?
Buffer
Yeah, this is this is easy, isn't it?
I was just being stupid.
Yeah, because I forgot that it's fine if
there is extra stuff on the buffer
uh because it gets null termed.
So now we have to do
X-Men.
I have to leave it for now.
Charar label.
We do draw text.
your margin.
Oh, and then this is width.
Not quite, my guy.
Not bad, but not quite.
And this is supposed to be two times
margin.
There we go. That's quite nice, don't
you think?
Wait, why is the label like 4242?
Didn't that seem messed up? Didn't I use
that for something?
Empty.
Uh because I do it before.
I do it before plotting is the problem.
Okay, this is um
that was better at least.
tips on debugging a faulty DQN and
environment. uh you already have a
problem right there is that you're
debugging potentially a faulty algorithm
and a faulty environment. You want to
pick one or the other. You'll get a very
simple environment that you know is
correct
like puffer cart pole or pong or
something like that
and then try to debug your
implementation on it or vice versa.
Other than that look at clean RL. You
want to keep your code just as dead
simple as possible.
And uh the really annoying thing is that
you know algorithms like DQN kind of
suck. So uh you know it's hard to tell
if it's even working sometimes.
You might want to pick something
honestly even simpler than like breakout
and like pong and cartpole. Like these
environments that we have for our
debugging tests are because our
algorithms are actually good. You might
even need something simpler.
I'm thinking I'm going to try out the uh
the new low row machine next.
I get these tick labels.
That whole machine behind me, you can
kind of see it.
You can't really
I've got like this whole three stack
tower back
And what we get to do
to move this guy
Not bad.
Are too small and too large.
That doesn't seem like it's using the
right font, does it?
It's not using the right font.
I don't know what happens though if the
axis is not zero.
Leave it for now.
Do the same for y real quick.
Yes.
Draw a line
Uh, yes. And then this one does need to
be pro, right?
Let's see what the default gives us.
I'm garbage.
Total garbage.
Okay,
let's see what it did.
Wait,
the X position needs to be
Yeah, it's still giving me way too many
ticks for some reason.
Tick label size. Ah, this has got to
bex.
Why?
Okay, this is already way way better.
Uh oh, and then we also don't do
Yeah, the ticks don't get rotated.
[ __ ]
Yeah, the ticks do not get rotated. That
actually
makes it better.
I like doing just like a bit of generic
programming like this once in a while
where like I'm doing something that is
going to help uh a lot of our RL stuff,
but it's really just generic
programming.
I really enjoy doing this type of stuff.
Like one of the things like uh working
on simulations is also a lot of fun.
Sometimes I like doing the science stuff
too, but like
I really like having the variety and
coming back to just doing some pure
The margin
minus tick size
And this doesn't plot anything.
Full story, bro.
See height minus
oh well this is totally wrong.
Yeah. So this is supposed to be y pause
and then the y so x pause is supposed to
be
uh args do margin. Yes. It's like
supposed to be like this, right? And
then we do
that's pretty good.
That's pretty pretty good.
up here.
This is supposed to be
Yeah, it's literally just zero.
All right.
Obviously, that's too much. And it's the
thing is it's probably not going to be
even.
I'll have to think about that.
But like for now is pretty good, right?
At least we have something that kind of
resembles a plot.
Yeah. So, this thing renders 700 FPS.
So,
we're happy with that.
I not get myself a new coffee. I just
drank it.
Right.
I think I have to think a little bit
about the 3D plot.
That's going to be the tough bit. I may
as well do it while I'm still relatively
fresh as well.
Let me go get a set of rose in.
Hey Kung. Yeah, this is a new thing. So
the idea here is I have this awesome viz
and like I'm going to definitely be able
to put together the biggest data set of
uh like public visualization data set of
RL ever. But I can't really easily ship
this thing and even if I do it's kind of
crappy and slow.
So
if I just make something uh in Rayb I
can stick it in the browser, it'll be
super fast and
like you'll be able to play with all
this in your browser and then I'll be
able to use all this plotting stuff in
the future as well. It's just like
really nice.
So I don't know, maybe this is kind of
stupid in the sense that like do I
really need to be spending my time doing
plots in C? Maybe, maybe not. But like
honestly, I don't think it's entirely
stupid because like the modern highle
programming uh highle programming stack
is just so utterly stupid that it's
literally almost easier to do it in C.
Like even if I had just a basic canvas
library that implements like axes with
ticks for two and 3D plots, like if I
literally just had that, then it would
be easier in C than it would be in
Python or JavaScript.
There's not like Is there like a C3D? I
mean, I should have looked this up.
Maybe I should go look at some of their
source.
This is like tiny for such a big
project.
Yeah, but the thing is this is like
this is kind of gigantic, right?
I mean, this looks super nice, though.
Some of it does, right?
I don't need all this, though.
It's It's
Why do all the plots kind of have the
same like retro vibe as well, you know?
This is the problem when I get these
giant projects is like it's actually
kind of hard to even look at them.
Yeah. And then this is like not even
necessarily
Okay. Okay. Well, I'll have to think of
Oh, that looks cool.
This isn't That's actually really solid.
Um, this is still too big of a project
to use.
I think what I'm just going to have to
think about is like how I do the minimum
amount of implementing on top of Ray Lib
So, basically, Finn, I literally if I
can just figure out 2D and 3D axes,
like that's honestly the only really
hard part I can even think of is just
the annoying getting the axes and stuff
right. The just the basics of having
your figures not be graphically a mess.
Honestly, stuff is not that hard
otherwise. I actually was thinking of
doing something like this. We have this
like drag and drop type interface, but
yeah,
I don't even know why I let anyone talk
me into putting those at all.
I'm signed in on the other browser. Hang
on.
Okay, quick set and then we uh keep on
this
That is a willy a uh really
well-designed piece of equipment.
Welcome.
What have I been doing while I was
offline?
prototype for this
buffer constellation large scale
visualization
few things for clients few other things
as well.
Apparently, when you write a post that
makes a bunch of people mad and then you
write a follow-up post where you say,
"Actually, screw all you people." Then
they go, "Oh, okay. I guess screw us
then."
Dang. I didn't even realize that that
low was that good.
It's got a It's got a flip down seat on
it. You know how like a lot of low rows
in combo units, they just like, oh yeah,
there's a low row. There's you can sit
on the floor and row and it's just super
annoying because you're never going to
go get sit like sit down on the hard
floor.
This one just has a super easy flip seat
where it goes from a lap pull to a low
row instantly.
Really nice.
Now maybe I will finally stop skipping
back day.
Okay. So,
right, what we were going to do is think
about
think about 3D
cuz basically once I go to 3D, am I not
just screwed?
Okay.
Options for 3D.
I'm not really a screw, am I?
Like
I don't want to have to make my own
Like I don't want to have to make my own camera thing, right?
Welcome.
Have you What?
What are you on about?
So, basically, let me just explain the
thing I'm thinking about here, right?
So, I'm trying to just make a little
lightweight plotting thing and see so
that I can take this visualization with
this stupid Python stack that's annoying
to put online and it's annoying to run
locally and all that and just have it
run. So like you can literally just do
this and you'll have your visualizations
locally, right?
but the only thing is it would be a lot
easier if I only needed 2D plots,
right? But after pretty extensive
thinking about this um last week, I
think I need this plot. Like there's
just no way around me needing
like there's just no way that I won't
need this 3D plot, you know?
And a 3D plot, if I just do it like
this, like from one angle, a 3D plot
really is not useful until you can do
this, right? Because like you're doing
it on a 2D screen.
You really need to like be able to zoom
around it and stuff.
Do I have to do this?
But like the problem with this is right
with this type of plot I can kind of
just say okay I'll draw this
but with this it's like now I need this
whole camera system.
So I kind of have to write it
differently from before, right?
And then like
probably I also need to
like I need to do all these labels as
well, right? Like this is the main thing
is getting the labels right.
I could just not, right? I could just
have it be
something like this where it's it's
interactive.
I could get rid of the background, which
is already kind of noisy anyways.
And then I could just put like an XYZ
diagram at the top with like steps,
cost, and perf.
Okay. I hadn't thought of that. I had
not thought of that.
Have you watched the I actually have not
watched the podcast surprisingly. So, I
kind of do AI all day and
uh when I'm like not doing AI, I'm
usually not listening to like AI related
podcasts and stuff normally because just
like
I don't know listening to like people
set the narrative about AI like podcast
content it just sort of pisses me off.
So, pretty much outside of this, uh, the
only things I really do is I work out. I
listen to audiobooks. That's pretty much
it.
And I don't listen to non-fiction
either. It's mostly like a creative
inspiration and it like clears my mind
of other stuff. And then pretty much
outside of just those two things, I'm
just doing AI, not really engaging with
other stuff in AI.
And the more I stick to that, the
happier I am and the more productive I
am as well. I've noticed
it's like a pretty clear thing.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly. Solita.
Um,
so yeah, I really don't like to be part
of that whole zeitgeist. I kind of just
like doing my thing.
Every single person who writes a stupid
reply on this is getting that a freaking
meme because it's at this point it's
literally you all just failed elementary
school.
Let's make a couple plots to start with,
right?
don't want to go to conferences
to present my paper. Are you doing
conferences correctly?
So what you do at conferences is you go
present your paper not the way you
present it to reviewers. You present it
whatever the hell way you want to
present your work and you talk to people
and then you just like book one-on-one
meetings with everybody that you are
interested in talking to who you haven't
met. And then if you've been around
conferences for a while and have friends
who go to conferences, you book a couple
dinners with those friends that you
haven't seen in the last like year and
you talk about what you're doing lately
in research. That's how you do
conferences.
You don't go to talks.
Uh you sometimes dip around a few of the
posters if there's anything you want to
see, but that's about it.
To be fair, I don't like going to
conferences either, but that's mostly
because I don't like traveling that
much.
I kind of like traveling once every 3 to
four months.
And I like traveling to go to a new
place to work because stuff gets stale
for me if I spend too long in one spot.
But it also I don't like to spend too
little time. I like to spend like a
season
in one This
I may be able to actually spell the name
of the project.
you're working on puffer constellation.
Yeah. So, what I'm doing FBR right now
is I am working on uh just seeing how
tough it would be to port some of the
visualizations to see
Ooh,
is cool.
But, uh, what's going on with it?
Why is this not
something happened There.
Yeah. So, FBR that like this is
something that you get when you use the
heavy [ __ ] like this. Uh I might be able
to implement that. We will see.
There's all sorts of stuff I can
implement. Like honestly, a lot of these
little features aren't even that hard.
Just like getting the whole thing to be
consistent and look like not a mess is
the hard part. I mean, even this type of
a thing, it like
you can see it kind of like does this
weird stuff.
Like this doesn't even feel great as
like a this is supposed to be like the
Enterprise polished [ __ ] thing. And
this doesn't even feel great to use. So,
this one's pretty cool, though. Look,
see these hyperparameter regions?
I can do stuff like this.
Oh, yeah. It's not running, but um you
can basically see the lighter region it
is, the more that the hyperparameters
are over there. There's all sorts of
cool graphs we're going to be able to
do. Honestly, these are pretty easy to
make. These aren't that hard.
Um,
the ones that are going to be the tough
ones are just like this and this,
but really it's just like the base
figure thing. And then these interactive
things, I actually already have Ray
Gooey for this. So, this is not going to
be that hard either.
First time on stream. What are you
building today? Welcome. Uh the deal
with the stream, I'm a reinforcement
learning researcher. I run a small
private lab. We do high performance
learning infrastructure simulations and
the like. They're all in puffer.ai. It's
all open source. I stream all the dev.
Today I'm working on the latest thing
which is buffer constellation. This is
large scale visualization for um tens of
thousands maybe even a hundred thousand
simultaneous experiments. This is just a
hacky prototype and I'm currently
porting it to C.
Okay. So, why is this thing not
rendering
the way it should be?
Oh, you know, I bet it's this get width.
I bet that this does the entire screen
with right.
There we go. Now, this one renders
cleanly.
And uh
wait, why is only one of them render
cleanly?
Didn't it render all four?
Wait really
like how
I wonder is it just like drawing them
all on top of each other?
Yeah, it's drawing them all on top of
each other. Uh, so why is it doing that?
If
How the heck is it drawing them all on
top of each other?
Oh, wait. Source position tint.
Is this it? Draw texture texture source
position
tint. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. I just had the args mixed up
in my head, man.
Boom.
Okay. And now we're going to make this a
little smaller, I believe, cuz this is
too big. Um
two is this and then it's
uh
looks sick. Yeah. So, it's actually
there's going to be uh something more
than just this. So, the other reason I'm
doing this is
Okay, so you know how Neptune and Wani
kind of just suck performance-wise.
Check this out. So, ignore the coloring
here, right?
Imagine that you just have access to
like select an environment and like
instead of this lagging forever, uh
well, it's cuz I'm not running it
actually here. Let me let me give you
the proper view
cuz this is going to be really sweet.
So once I've implemented this, it's
going to be like a literally uh a 50line
program to just take this exact same
thing
and then give you Oh, I want to look at
mobile. I want to look at grid like
this. Oh, I want to look at uh score.
Oh, well it's score versus score. So
score versus learning rate. Oh, okay
cool. So imagine you just have this and
then this runs locally and you can do
like all this crap and it just runs like
instantly however you like. It runs on
web. It runs like in a local app. It
runs on tens of thousands of data points
from like all of your local data files.
And you don't have to like wait for
Neptune to lag 10 years or wand to lag
10 years in order to do basic
visualizations.
And it'll be like way way more
responsive than this application is as
well.
You talk a bit about your view on credit
assignment as it relates to what
like
Typically, it's handled by some form of
advantage estimation.
Um,
advantage estimation is like really
really central to doing it well. It's
probably the main distinguishing factor
between different classes of RL
algorithms is how they do credit
assignment or at least one of the main
distinguishing factors.
There we go.
Why? Where did my tick labels go
in?
I see.
Ah, yes. I see.
Uh,
well, were you asking us like with
respect to the article that I wrote or
uh just in general
because they're kind of two different
things, right?
I'm going to have to take a few minute
break after this.
And you go
there
work.
Really?
Well, I'll figure it out in a bit. Um,
don't let me forget to unmute my mic
when I come back. I'll be back in a few.
Okay.
More like an article
review.
If you're still here, grow. So, yeah,
it's important.
Um, but if you want to pick like what is
the thing that makes RL RL
if you just get to pick one thing, it's
interaction, not credit assignment.
Credit assignment is an algorithmic
detail.
right, let's see what the heck was going
on here.
Oh, it's not freaking Python.
Uh,
margin
really.
This is like the default not getting
set.
Oh, you dummy.
So, two things. First of all,
I'm sick of this thing
uh popping up my camera like that.
And second of all,
we just do args.
Yes.
Thanks for the comment. Yeah. So, I
mean, basically, so here's the thing.
Wo, like that article, I wrote that
because one, people asked for it, and
two, my previous post blow up blew up in
the stupidest way possible cuz I said,
"Hey, offline RL is an RL. RL is about
interaction." And then people say like,
"But that makes me feel bad because I my
identity is tied to RL and like I think
what my work is RL." It's like no, it's
not like you're getting kicked out of
the cool kids club, right? It's like if
you think about it for two seconds, if
you have to pick a thing that is the
essence of the field, it's interaction.
And you can't like historical this that
it's like literally in Sutton and Bardau
as well. even if you want to take that
angle, which isn't a good one to take.
Um, so like when you put something
that's not interaction into the field,
like it just loses meaning. So all I was
doing is saying, hey, like this is
screwing up the identity of the field
when you smuggle stuff in like this. And
then people took it either as like a
personal thing or like, you know, we're
talking about but like this looks very
similar to these algorithms. Yeah. But
it's missing the key defining element,
right? So it's not like you know to what
extent are these methods similar? It's
not like you know oh should we include
it's it's none of that stuff. It's
literally just a very simple what is the
identity of the field? Is it that okay
no it's not. So that's not RL.
I had like a million different comments
from people uh that were making very
good arguments for things that had
nothing to do with the original thing
that I wrote.
Okay, so we have this now. Very solid.
Um,
what do we do about it
is my question.
presumably. We're going to do
Where's the dash?
And did I lose my dash?
I lost my dash.
All right. At most four drop downs. This
one's got a couple sliders. No big deal.
So we just leave
we leave like an extra little bit of
space.
Oh yeah, I don't care when I post. Uh,
I mean it shouldn't even be a
controversial thing though is that like
it was a controversial thing because
people can't read and like psychology is
stupid. There wasn't actually like a
meaningful discussion of any variety in
there. It was just like purely stupid,
Uh, what? What's going on here?
Oh, I see.
Good enough.
And then this will be legend. So, this
will actually fit nicely.
Put some UI bars in there
and it'll be good.
need ray gooey.
Do we have Rayu in settings?
this is the code for it as well, right?
Yeah, this is the code.
did Ray Gooey just go? There we go.
Yeah. Let's just see their example.
Okay. Okay. So, this thing here
to So,
What? Oh, it's width and height, isn't
it?
Position size
XY with height. No.
I click it. Does it show up?
Nothing happens.
You can click it too fast, which is kind
of weird.
Can't drag it.
We don't need this anyways, right?
Oh, yay. I get to do it to this guy. He
always posts stuff like stupid [ __ ]
And I've read his code.
Where where was the article?
Let's see.
I need to get a larger screenshot of it.
Do this.
Why is it not Oh, it needs to have a a
different aspect.
like this.
Like this
not have a draw tool on this stupid
thing.
Oh, come on. He doesn't have a draw
tool.
Ah,
all right. Whatever. We'll just leave
this. I like this.
I should have cleaned the whole thing
here. Let me let me get him the whole
thing
and not edit it.
Why can't I edit this stupid thing?
Whatever.
It's just like, okay, you failed your
reading exam.
And there's no heavy lifting. It's
literally you just failed your reading
exam.
Like if you're going to write stupid
[ __ ] at least make sure you've read the
stuff that you're going to write stupid
[ __ ] about. Period.
Like if you're going to be a dick, you'd
either be f you have to either be funny
or correct. You're neither.
Okay, there's this drop down.
There examples for this thing.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. I missed that post from
X. Have you ever looked at Schmidt
Huber's upside down RL
algorithm?
No. Does it work or is it a Schmidt
Huberism?
He doesn't have Ray Gooey on here.
You really should have Ray Gooey up on
this thing.
Otherwise, I have to look up stupid [ __ ]
like this.
Oh, I don't know why I literally wasn't
even paying attention.
need both of these things. Kind of
annoying.
We're just going to see if this thing
works.
Do we drop down
box
and then how does it work? They just do
uh
Yeah,
it's just something like this.
Oh, and then instead of this you
actually have to do
this open.
Selected item and then we do items of
drop down active.
One,
two.
I don't like how it seems to be skipping
my clicks.
They just need to go faster. Sir,
Um, this Yeah, this is skipping my
clicks.
It doesn't seem to just be FPS related
is the weird thing.
We'll leave this alone for now and we'll
assume that we can figure that out
later.
I mean, literally, it's like I'm going
to [ __ ] mail some of these
researchers in elementary school how to
read book.
Like
there are exams for grad school, right?
Like a chapter book's too hard.
You don't even have to be able to read
freaking chapter books. It's like a
paragraph.
It's like the thing is I don't actually
think that they're that stupid that they
can't read. It's that they have
something in their head that they want
to believe and then they'll just
interpret everything as antagonistic to
that and their brain just skips it,
which I suppose is kind of the same as
not reading, but like
[ __ ] hell.
So stupid.
Like you have zero zero neuroplasticity
left. Zero.
[Applause]
Funny thing is I've read that guy's
code, too.
Okay, so this thing here,
we can actually use this now.
This gets us some drop downs, right?
We'll have to figure out how we put in a
bunch of these.
No, let me just see if it's this local
mode.
I have to hold the mouse button down, it
looks like.
Isn't that weird? Like if I click it, if
I do the mouse up.
Yeah, it's if you do the mouse up and
the mouse down on the same frame.
Is that K? I think I know who that is.
Hello, welcome.
Oh, yeah, that is. Hello. Welcome.
You've caught me in uh one of the
periodic rant about dumb stuff and
research things rather than the build
cool stuff things.
But building cool stuff is also on the
agenda.
This just bothers me that like
This is a fundamental framework bug. I
think I don't know what I'm going to be
able to do. I mean, I can ask Rayson
about this, but I think the right call
is just ignore this for now and like
build out the rest of the dashboard and
then we come back to it and then
and then yeah, that should be okay,
right?
Yeah, I think that's all we're going to
be able to do. So, let's do
Well, let's do like 300ish.
And uh
I'm trying to think if I want I don't
really want to do this as part of the
int dropdown active. Oh, wait, wait.
Maybe it's just GPT being stupid, right?
Is this drop down active?
I wonder if this is just not the way
that you're supposed to use this
component.
I swear if this was just GPT being dumb
or Grock.
Not I don't want to go back to Grock.
Where's Where is it?
this thing not have a drop down in it
somewhere.
What's it called? Gooey dropdown box.
Wait, what?
There it is.
Command drop down thoughts.
Okay. So, I think that there's then
specifically something weird with this,
right?
Drop down edit mode
drop down active.
Okay.
Uh, we need some sort of
margin, don't we?
Yeah, there's like this whole spacing
annoyance, right? This is the reason
that like honestly the stuff with all
these UI components, it's actually very
easy to chuck something together. It's
just all the spacing and layout stuff
that's a major major pain.
Um, I'm trying to think if there's a
better way I have than doing this just
manually.
I can get it so the chords are
normalized at the least.
Do you draw the full UI? Maybe.
Let me go think about that for a second.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. UI annoying. It's just
the spacing and layout crap. Um I'll get
it though. I've still got some time. I'm
probably going to want to put in like a
little bit of time on another project
while I'm here. We'll see. Uh even
today, but you know, regardless, let me
go to the restroom. I'll go do uh one
more set and then I think I have a
couple ideas.
All right. Yeah, you just can't read, my
guy.
is is
one possible out.
If he's ESL, I'll give him a pass.
Testler.
Nope. Doesn't look like it. I think you
just can't [ __ ] read. Okay, cool.
Well,
my critics are illiterate.
If my only critics are illiterate, then
I would I uh proclaim victory.
Okay. So, the thing I was thinking here
is if I do each of the UIs,
the annoying thing is there kind of two
things you have to figure out, right? If
you do,
I could just do like cumulative offsets,
I guess.
I mean, from the corner it's easy
enough.
Oh, wait. Does this actually If it has a
built-in margin, then that's
Yeah, it doesn't. Okay.
Drop down edit mode is not a mode
on active.
How are we going to have it so I can't
click
Okay.
I must have just done something careless
here now.
Oh yeah, look.
Stupid thing.
It's literally just the auto the
autocomplete messing with me.
You see, it just doesn't know this. So,
it's like giving me garbage suggestions
and I'm not noticing. This is why AI is
bad. Okay. So, now this is good. We have
this
little uh dash thing up here.
minus settings
Very nice.
And
I guess it just puts this margin at the
top for the heck of it.
and then the only thing is it needs to
be at
drop down with
This is actually like these backtoback
buttons things like the backto back
compact aesthetic is not bad. I'd
actually be totally down just having
like,
you know, buttons be like this and not
having to I mean, just the best way to
deal with spacing is just not having to
deal with it, right?
so
there's several spots to go from here.
Let's try to get
a working version of this
with these two on all the different
plots
and actually hooked up to controlling
what data gets plotted. I think that's
going to be the uh the simplest like end
to end thing that matters that we can
get done right now.
I do not want to be checking X a ton
while I'm doing this like big blocker
research, but
it is somewhat entertaining.
This is like done kind of okay. It's
kind of funny though that the original
uh post like blew up to hundred some odd
thousand
like oh look here's something I can
write a stupid comment about. I will
therefore write a stupid comment.
I think I can do this manually. This bit
right.
it's just going to be like this is just
a stupid thing, right? Like
Wait, is this not
Can I not just use this directly
for JSON?
I'm trying to think like what I can load
this into.
Um
I don't really have a dictionary type
thing, right?
But I sort of This is one of those rare
cases.
It's easier to have something like this
though.
What's the easiest way? I just need like
some sort of spring map, right?
That's the annoying bit.
Yeah. I think it's just going to have to
be
We'll just do that and then we'll hook
this up to plot that
probably today
I've got another like few hours. So I
think we can probably do
uh the prototype of this that looks
decent enough for 2D
for this specific plot type.
I mean, literally, even just that is
already kind of powerful, right? If you
just have something where you can super
quick just set yourself up four plots of
whatever types of variables you want and
it's like nice and snappy all in one
screen.
Obviously, there's stuff like I'd like
to be able to zoom in. I'd like to be
able to do a lot of different things,
but
it's possible that I might end up
needing to use the camera system. We
will see.
Camera system is kind of janky though.
It's like you get all sorts of
artifacting and crap.
Why the heck is this? So
hang on. Why did it write so much crap?
E value. Okay.
Can somebody please explain to me why
there's so like it's is it like just
standard in C to check every time you
allocate memory for errors?
Isn't that like kind of stupid?
The vast majority of programs do not
have graceful fallbacks if you are just
out of memory, right?
I guess the idea is you just don't want
it to seg fault.
Yeah. So, this is just like written.
This is why you don't just copy paste
LLM code. This is kind of garbage.
This is like kind of just garbage.
Let me see what the heck it decided to
even do.
So, this is the one where it's like,
yeah, you might need to kind of allocate
That
Yeah, I don't like this. Let me think
what I can do different with this.
Like, tell me this isn't just stupid,
right?
Well, you don't have to clean up,
right? There's no reason to clean up the
memory if you're just going to kill the
program anyways.
Damn it. This is why I hate using MLMs
for stuff cuz it's like now it's like so
tempting. I could just copy paste this,
but this is garbage, All right.
and do that. Let's see if it produces
less code.
What is next on the exercise list for
today?
Maybe dumbbell rows.
Could do some dumbbell rows.
I think I can at least work with this,
right? Like I can go from here
and uh I can probably
I can probably edit this
And what was the uh the get
just need the oneliner
Ah, and then this thing needs to get
set.
Does it can change? Yes, it can change.
And then actually you don't need this
this.
Okay. So we have our init window.
we can just do it like this.
cost
Okay. So, we need to get the index, I
suppose.
Um,
something like this maybe
different systems.
Uh it depends on the M convert and like
so right now for some reason 5090 is way
faster than 4090 on a lot of M even
though it really shouldn't be.
There's some hardware architecture
differences and shenanigans going on for
sure.
All right, cool. So,
boom.
Except that uh that seems to have done
double time,
which is kind of funny, but it does make
sense, right?
We'll just do like this. Whoops.
And uh
this gets a clear on it as well.
there. Not a begin drawing on this
thing.
Okay,
not bad.
I mean, we can like obviously make this
for multiple plots.
Um, and we have a lot we can do from
here. And we're still under 500 lines
even with all the garbage. So, use the
restroom real quick and get a drink
and maybe get a set of dumbbell rows in.
Once I'm done with Mario torch properly,
what resources
and to torch properly
like optimizing it? They have a
profiler. It's kind of bad.
The main thing that you need to know is
that you have to CUDA sync. You have to
sync CUDA to get accurate timings, which
is what our profiler does. Um,
let's see. There's the whole compile
thing where like compile can get rid of
a lot of the graph overhead, but there
are only certain configs that are
limited by that.
There's kind of just a lot of different
stuff. It's going to end up being some
mix of cudigraphs, compile,
general purpose timings and
optimizations.
There might be some kernel fusion stuff.
I don't know.
There's definitely like timings of
architectures,
uh, MFU valves,
lots of stuff.
I mean, I have four different plots,
right?
I can probably just make
a a thing that handles each plot.
alos.
Oh, that's a way deeper rabbit hole. You
got to check my guide for that. My RL
guide has a lot of good info there.
I just put it all under args.
Seems wrong.
Can't even do it all under args because
it's different per plot.
I'm just trying to do this manually
first so I can get a sense of it and
then we'll see afterwards. Right.
This can almost certainly just be put
into some sort of like little loop, but
I don't want to think about how it to do
it right yet because like there are
other things that are going to change
basically
and um
it's going to be easier to do this and
then figure it out.
At least we have like a working thing
that we can start
Is this good? Now,
if I put this thing up here,
does.
It stands to reason
this
here as well.
and then
just do options.
Okay. So now we can take this thing
and we can replicate this.
Do it again.
Oops.
That
chunk
All right. So now
we have super hacky
um but should be functional
No.
Oh, the offset's dummy.
Yeah, you kind of borked that, didn't
you?
Whoops.
Uh, how do I fix this?
Okay, this is drop down with
second one was up here somewhere.
right. So, now
uh I can go get
Okay.
And then
let's do like this.
zero for all these. And we'll just do
like
Okay.
So we actually have here right like some
reasonable plots
Wait, was that even worse than I had
read originally?
Oh, yeah. He's actually illiterate.
Okay, cool. I didn't even realize it was
that bad. Oh my god. Okay.
What in the No, we're not doing starst
star whatever [ __ ]
Prefer it just be static.
This is so freaking annoying.
Yeah, string processing in C is kind of
a pain. I'll admit
string processing in C kind of just
sucks.
This is like the high level lowlevel
thing where it's like all right I can do
string processing and see but it's like
come on
Yeah, that's kind of a problem that this
doesn't do uh
rolling drop down, right?
And then the labels as well need to be
fixed.
Well, I mean, this is obviously uh
could be formatted a bit better here,
huh?
But hey, I mean, we do have
like look at this. We have like this
super fast exploration tool
and not very much time at all.
They're obviously uh need some polish.
This clicking bug bothers the hell out
of me.
What the heck?
Oh, this is funny. Look, you can
actually see like little groups of
Huh.
Fun.
Uh, okay. So,
350.
Next thing is how do we make this less
of a mess?
How do we fix up little UI bugs? And if
I can get like a usable version of this
today would be nice.
Alternatively,
let me see if they sent me um
should be stuff in.
Okay. Okay. Alternatively, it is four.
And I could go do
uh there's the other thing I could go do
is fix some of the meta stuff real
quick.
That might not be bad.
I'll decide momentarily.
Let's see what they said.
Pull from
What in the
That is so stupid. How do they have it
so messed up that they like literally
Literally just have to do this crap
because
Apparently, this is the command that's
supposed to work.
Okay. So then
they say
500 million steps. Lovely
training rotation. Easy shaped
Uh, where's my freaking code games
config?
Is this on the puffer box?
Like
So, um,
can I just do
Well,
So, we are going to attempt to have this
work
and we will
I wonder if it makes sense to have the
whole different engine for um
or like the whole camera mode for 3D and
not for Uh 2D.
We'll see.
Okay. So
Oops.
Okay. Well, this one is easy. This is
just a container reboot.
I think what we'll do is I'll leave this
set up on this box. So, I'll just have
this box for that. And then when they uh
inevitably reply, I'll just go to this
instead of having to switch my
workspaces locally constantly.
Yeah, that's what I'll do. So, I go back
to uh unless they reply to this, I go
back for a little bit to
my plotting work.
Be chill.
One more set of dumbbell rows.
Then
I will have a couple hours left in which
to get some ab work in before dinner.
And hopefully
I'm trying to think if I want to do
other plot types just yet.
We could kind of just forge ahead on
those plot types.
Well,
we go back to this then.
I think we're going to have some fun.
We're going to do the uh the 3D plot
right now.
I'm getting rather hungry.
Only thing
All we need to do
turn this into a 3D plot.
What's wrong with this?
All of them.
Kind of bad.
That wasn't happening before.
Oh, you know what though?
Hang on.
Um,
nothing seems wrong with that.
Okay. I mean, like,
it would have to be this, wouldn't it?
Like, what what the hell else can it be?
it. Yeah, it wasn't doing this before.
All of them
as soon as it brings up the menu.
Well,
Mhm.
Yeah. Nim.
The heck.
I very rarely get this type of crap
happening.
I'd rather not have to revert the whole
damn thing, but let me see.
Where do I go? And I don't want to I
don't want to go do that. Hang on.
Rather fight it a little bit more than
have to mess with that.
Uh there's some like weird
you Okay.
I mean Hang on. Let me try something.
I'm just really careful with this.
Oh, okay.
So then this is unrelated to the Z
[ __ ]
let me just assume that it's some weirdo
[ __ ] with this.
Like on one hand I'm so sick of Docker
doing [ __ ] and on the other hand
it's like do I really want to UV
everything?
Like UV is not exactly good either.
Like you pick your poison.
Okay. It's not
early.
Okay, there's some hardcoded Bors
[ __ ] I think
we're going to ignore that for now.
Okay. So I can actually see the sphere
here
when it 0 0.
Let's just see what the heck is
happening.
Oh, I see.
I see.
There we go.
Beers.
Yay.
Oh, that was quick. I started on the
thing I was doing. Uh
oh, research end. Okay, cool. Let me see
what this is.
Oh,
that is some solid progress.
I have been working on
Let me see if it'll run.
Well, I'm sure that the latest build
will run. All right.
this port.
Thank you. After story
gym got to have the flag training
facility.
This is the uh going to be the viz for
constellation.
I'm already seeing like all sorts of
stuff just like all sorts of weird
trends I hadn't noticed before,
Is it not?
Why can't I remember? Like
I think maybe it did.
there. Oh, camera orbit. It's this thing
right.
Why do I only get one line? That's so
weird.
Oh, okay.
Cool.
blah blah blah rel doesn't provide it.
Yes, it does. Shut up.
That's what it's called, right? Ellipse.
Am I going nuts?
No. What is it?
Ellipsis.
All right.
box, right? The original reason. This is
why X sucks because you go to do one
thing and do another thing.
All
what this does
of a mess.
Huh?
Why did this one not show up?
I see.
Yeah.
Oh,
I think you just do this right
for the check box. Is this it?
So, what is it? It's like agent steps
uh score
like this.
We don't need to log the score variable.
Yeah,
I mean this is going to take a little
bit of work, but um
the basis of it
Let it progress. Well, it's not going to
remember the uh the earlier levels if
you just like put it onto the later
levels as it completes them.
The thing
hoping it would learn enough from the
first level.
Unfortunately,
not how it works.
It's just that it's like super smashed
together now, right?
No, that's what I need to figure out how
to do. Well,
can I train a puffer two adversarial
policies?
Um,
you can do adversarial selfplay.
You'd have to hack a policy wrapper to
do it with uh two different policies.
Actually, Spencer is messing with that
at the moment. Um,
easiest thing to do is to just make like
a network that has two subn networks and
then split data across it.
If you set that up correctly, that'll
just that should just
Mhm. Yeah. So, the problem with
adversarial stuff in general, right,
is like it's established that you can do
this stuff.
Um, but then the details of how to not
make it horribly jank are not
established, if you know what I mean.
That's actually one of the things we're
going to be working on pretty soon here.
Just only got so many so much time for
all these freaking projects.
Excited for that part. Gatekeeping the
stream.
There's no gatekeeping in the stream.
It's just research.
I'm not going to tell you it's easy if
it's not.
Okay. So, I just have to take um
What is this? I just have to get
Is it this one that I just get rid of?
This just goes to zero, right?
One text. Yeah, this goes to zero.
Okay, here we go.
So,
uh, and then
yeah, these boxes got screwed up.
ocean.
You're not that far off. Honestly, FPR,
there are uh we do have some projects,
I'll say.
Oh, I see. So, we want y to be score,
right?
Yeah.
Well, at least there's something here,
right?
think how we were going to do this? I
guess I should just look at how I did
this originally, right?
Oh, okay. So, I need to like pre-process
to be able to do this one.
And then this one has a bunch of crap on
it right now.
And we don't know if that one's even
useful.
I may as well just try to make this this
thing look better for the time being.
well the axes are normmed to the data
first of all
I can do That
load model path.
Uh,
if it does, I don't think it correctly
handles optimizer state. I could be
wrong though.
All right.
Uh I think we just have to norm
it comes down to
Yeah. So, you can't do it that way
either. It's so annoying.
I just do I can't just do it all at once
either, though. Stupid.
correct thing to do is whatever the hell
this is, right? Which is
Okay. Well, this is nice, right?
Yeah, at least get this to rotate
around.
blocked by cam. What? Oh, shoot. And I
also forgot my app training stuff. All
right.
Um,
yeah, I got to go do a few quick sets. I
forgot I got stuck into this. We will
continue on this tomorrow.
Um, okay. Hey, thanks for folks uh to
folks for tuning in. I may or may not be
live later in the evening. I might have
to do some client work. I think I'm
probably going to do some client work,
but I should be back around 10:30 a.m.
tomorrow. So, for a few folks who've
been watching all day, thank you for
tuning in. All my stuff's on puffer.ai.
the puffer if you want to help me out
for free and join the discord if you